russia's ambitious naval strategy
vladimir putin says the us is the
biggest threat to his global maritime
goals he's promised to equip warships
with unprecedented weapons
so what does this new naval strategy
mean and how will it be viewed in
washington this is inside story
[Music]
hi there welcome to the program i'm kim
vanell president vladimir putin has
announced his planned expansion of
russia's naval power singling out the us
as the biggest obstacle putin signed a
new naval doctrine on sunday accusing
washington of trying to dominate the
world's oceans
the 55-page document states that nato's
movements threaten moscow's borders and
details a plan to strengthen russia's
geopolitical position
in a speech to mark navy day putin did
not directly mention the war in ukraine
instead he thanked military personnel
and pledged to defend russian interests
in the black and as of seas
we have openly outlined the boundaries
and zones of russia's national interests
both economic and strategic first of all
these are our arctic waters the waters
of the black okhotsk and bering seas as
well as the baltic and kuril straits we
will ensure their protection firmly and
by all means for all of us the
motherland is a sacred concept and its
defense is one of the highest duties and
the meaning of life for each and every
one of us
let's bring in our guests in moscow is
sergey markov director of the institute
of political studies he's also a former
spokesman for president vladimir putin
in vienna is wolfgang pustzai a security
defense analyst and former austrian
defense attache
and in new york is lawrence brennan a
retired u.s navy captain and adjunct
professor of law at fordham university a
very warm welcome to you all uh thank
you for joining us i'd like to begin uh
with you mr markov if i may um seeing as
you were a former spokesman for
president putin and may have some
insight into the thinking in his in his
circle i just want to get your take on
this new naval doctrine what it means
and i guess more importantly what it
signifies
uh first of all i think
it will be a few
strategic documents
of
russian government which has to be
changed because now we live in a new
reality believe in the reality where uh
the policy of the united states of
america and another nature country
became very aggressive
united states overthrown democratically
elected president of ukraine imposed a
repressive undemocratic regime to
ukrainian people and
support aggressiveness against people in
donbass who were priceless against the
illegal
coup which happened in the kit
uh also we could see hybrid war uh which
orchestrated and led by united states of
america and
uh to which another members of nato
including european union countries uh
join so russia needs uh in this new
reality to change uh the
the bunch of its uh
strategic documents uh naval strategy
it's uh
one of them it's uh that's why it's
absolutely correctly clear uh you
described that as united states uh is
regarded as the major
threat to russian security interests and
united states attempt to block russia is
specifically regarded as as the biggest
threat
from the uh neville i would say ocean
and sea uh uh point of view okay i want
to call you there i want to pause you
there and just pick up on something you
said
describing this as a new reality and
passed it over to wolfgang pusty um
obviously in terms of the reasoning for
the war in ukraine the position of
ukraine and the west is is somewhat
different but i just want to get your
take on this new naval doctrine is this
uh does this signify a new reality
well i would say it's the new naval
doctrine is also somehow a reaction to
nato enlargement
nato enlargement in the north with
regard to finland and sweden this
weakens the geostrategic position of
russia in the north significantly
especially as in the case of a major war
between russia and nato nato would have
the capability to threaten the naval
bases of the northern fleet near
murmansk and that they
with regard to the development from the
previous 2015 doctrine i would say it's
no surprise it's more or less a logical
development
okay um mr lawrence brennan you're
you're a navy man what's your sort of
reaction to this naval doctrine and
what do you make of the timing obviously
you know russia is at war with ukraine
but is there any importance around the
timing of this
there there could be terrible importance
about the timing of this this undues
centuries of traditional maritime law
law of the high seas and undues more
than half a century of very good naval
relations between the former soviet navy
and the right now the russian navy and
the u.s navy
in the dark days of the early 1970s uh
the soviet navy in the u.s navy came to
an agreement called the incident sea
agreement inc agreement to prevent the
risk of unintentional or possibly
accidental harm between their ships it
was during the time of great hostilities
in the eastern mediterranean among the
arab nations in israel and we've had
good relations annual meetings and
resolution at at lower levels of
possible conflicts uh
we we have agreements that supplement
the law of the sea we have agreements
that supplement the rule of the road
rules of the road and we have fairly
good relationships uh when i was on the
aircraft carrier nimitz that launched
the raid uh to iran to try to rescue the
american hostages we always had a
russian or then a soviet surface ship
shadow
we we had some interesting uh
communications
at that time and got in trouble with
president carter for sending hockey
scores during the 1980 olympics but they
were professionally done there were no
real risks of collision no real risks of
weapons being fired accidentally or
intentionally this is a question then
for sergey markov uh over in moscow
there's been a lot of discussion about
this being a
reaction to the expansion of nato
is that the reason for this naval
doctrine how threatened does russia feel
right now
about nato
russia uh not so much concern about nato
especially about uh finland and uh
sweden joining nate
uh we know that uh uh because of the
treaties which exist between nato and
european union
and the membership of sweden and finland
and european union in fact we regarded
that finland and sweden already been
part of the nato anarchy we know that
defense ministers of finland and sweden
took part in all uh meetings of nato
defense ministers and uh also on the
grass root level also it was of
inter uh interconnection between nato
and finland this year so this situation
didn't change dramatically also was the
reason why we have been so much
against uh membership of ukraine uh
in nato is because nato is used as
weapon of force the
transformation of ukraine to the
anti-russia and to creating by
class threat to russia and to to format
to form the relation between russia and
ukraine as the relation between india
and pakistan it's what we doesn't like
for sure because it's a big strategic
threat to the russian security as
talking to the north now more russia
interesting and this is uh reflected in
this naval uh uh strategy russia want to
think uh
about security uh of the uh north
uh traffic uh
arctic way so called uh it's uh regarded
as an important uh
uh for economy and for the uh security
issue also and we want uh to defend
this arctic way from
any uh
any
aggressive behavior from the uh those
country which uh doesn't like uh such
way to be used for russian economy this
will be priority arctic polar
trade way okay wolfgang puss i can see
you want to jump in there before i get
your response i also want to ask you um
the main threat to russia according to
the doctrine is the strategic policy of
the usa to dominate the world's oceans
is that true is there a shift from the
u.s wanting to dominate the world's
waters
well at first with regards to nato
access of sweden and finland there is a
big difference for russia because for
the time being both versus amazon
theater partnership for peace and now
after the real full member of nato there
is a mutual defense clause which makes
the difference there is an integration
of both countries into nato command
structure
and the new naval doctrine of russia
counters also the perceived free threat
by these two additional nato countries
by account of rep in the arctic and with
referring to your question
for the united states
the freedom of shipping the freedom of
global shipping lines is a vital
strategic interest it's a vital
strategic interest in order to ensure
this the us navy needs to maintain a
presence all over the world at least
with regard to the global shipping rules
the russian new doctrine is a clear
mismatch a mismatch of strategic
objectives and available means
the russian navy has about 210 vessels
out of these 210 vessels about 55 are
fully functional blue water ocean-going
vessels and submarines about half of
them can be considered modern ships
this means it's unlikely that the
russians will be able to threaten
american sea control they are following
somehow the so-called french chern
according naval concept of the 19th
century which means their aim is not so
much to dominate the sea but to
challenge the usc control
all right i'd like to come back to you
sergey markov do you agree with that
assessment of uh russia's sort of uh
strategy in terms of its naval power and
sort of
how do you think all of this is likely
to be viewed by the other side as likely
to be viewed by the us
uh we know that there are very very big
difference about what americans thinking
and what americans
are talking and what americans doing
uh
you know
and
we know that they are talking everything
about aggressively of russia but in fact
they know for sure that russia's not
aggressive country
but uh they attack russia exactly
because they believe that russia are too
weak if russia will
will be not weak uh because of them they
will not attack it so uh and uh
it's one important point another point a
point about uh uh uh we understand you
know we should uh divide two
important uh
military uh things one is global nuclear
uh potential which is uh used by russia
uh uh first of all by uh strategic
submarines for some kind of uh taking
part in the
big nuclear catastrophical war
this worked more or less uh efficiently
and well
uh
but uh this situation and a warrior on
the ukrainian territory which we believe
russia has not against ukraine but
against proxy american army which uh
used
uh uh america ukrainian flag and uh as
issue that russian military navy was a
conventional uh uh wars appear to be not
so strong not so strong enough that's
why russia uh
vladimir putin announced ambitious uh
plan uh to build a new
uh
military uh
naval ships for the conventional uh wars
which we expected uh to our regret we
will have to take part in the future
okay wolfgang puss die i'd like to come
back to you um depending on which
analyst you talked to at the start of
the war it was discussed that um russia
had failed in its initial aims that it
wanted to go in take over ukraine or
take over large parts of ukraine and it
be done and that instead it's turned
into a war of attrition and that in fact
it wanted to to take over to take
control of the black sea was that ever
an aim was would russia ever have been
able to do that and if this is now a war
of attrition how well is russia placed
to to continue that
i would say at the beginning the russian
strategy was based on entirely wrong
assumptions
they did not believe that the ukrainian
armed forces would put up a stiff
resistance
actually their assumption was that the
vast majority of the russian
living in ukraine would join the russian
army in their advance they did not
believe that the west including the
united states would impose serious
sanctions on russia and if we have a
look on the military concept these quick
attacks the so-called operation maneuver
groups trying to reach kiev are a
typical example for these wrong
assumptions they believe that they could
get to kiev and the war would be over
they would have preferred to install a
russia-friendly government in kiev this
has obviously failed and they have now
changed their approach their strategy
this means it's about as if said a war
of attrition in the donbass they wanna
succeed in occupy the whole of the
donbas and if possible this means if
they're able to eliminate the vast
majority of the ukrainian forces they
would aim also to attack odessa and
advance to odessa to occupy the whole
black sea coast
if this is possible we will see in the
next weeks or months if the ukrainians
are able to uphold their resistance this
will certainly depend also on the amount
of weapon deliveries from the west
lawrence brennan we've talked a lot
about the strategy and the naval
strategy but i want to get a little bit
specific about some of the uh
announcements around this naval doctrine
so there are going to be hypersonic
missiles uh on some ships can you just
explain uh to us and to our audience at
home what they are
what sort of challenges they present for
potential combatants
sure
in simplistic terms the zircon missiles
which are on small russian naval
combatants
have a range of approximately a thousand
kilometers and have a speed of about 500
nautical mile which is also about 500
nautical miles they have a speed of nine
times the speed of sound which is uh
nearly 7 000 miles per hour wow they're
impossible stage to destroy
safely in flight now that doesn't mean
they're accurate that doesn't mean that
they will uh lock on but it means that
those who are defending against those
targets have to go back to early flight
errors particularly towards the end of
world war ii
and
the japanese kamikaze attacks manned
suicide planes and the aircraft and and
here the zircon missiles have to be
destroyed before they're launched that
means that the target is the ship
carrying them right now
the publicity is that the ships that
will carry them are relatively small
soviet russian naval
corvettes or destroyer type ships
their ability to defend their in
integration in larger groups are not
known that's one thing that will have to
be planned i am sure that the u.s naval
war college the technical people in the
navy are looking studying at this and
coming up with counter proposals how to
respond to it before it happens we also
have to work in a world where we hope
that no one begins an unprepared uh
unannounced first strike
that's not the policy of the united
states government
and hopefully is not the policy of the
russian government or any other
civilized government in the world just
before we move on from you uh mr brennan
the uh much anticipated grain deal has
finally gotten underway today um
allowing ships from ukrainian ports to
go through down the black sea um and
into the bosphorus in istanbul to get
much-needed grain to avoid a basically a
worldwide food crisis i mean how tenuous
is that how dangerous is that is there
the potential for this to go wrong
there's always potential for
hazards of the sea uh and most of those
are relatively benign things that's why
the insurers at lloyd's and in tokyo and
in europe uh ensure maritime risk that
happens uh
there are certain excluded risks war
risks that are under special insurance
in london particularly not exclusively
and and those are things we're looking
at but this grain uh from what i read
earlier today is bound uh
for lebanon where there's desperate need
uh
if the russians have agreed to allow
grain to leave and the turkish
government which controls the bosphorus
and the exit and entrance into the black
sea turkey and member of nato if turkey
permits that and and supports it and
there's no opposition and no hostility
things will work okay um they're still
and there's still uncertainty as to what
really is going to happen and if there's
a blockade of
ukraine grain and economic warfare in
that form as as you say there does seem
to be a consensus among around among all
parties about the importance of this
working um sergey markov i'd like to
come back to something you said talking
about the the arctic ocean the
importance of the arctic ocean is
actually set out in this doctrine why is
it so important for russia the arctic
ocean what's happening there
uh arctic
ocean becoming more and more important
for russia because a few
reasons first of all because of global
warming
now we see uh more opportunities for the
trade through arctic ocean uh uh
following has a
russian uh
shore cost
and
it's one it can create a very good uh
uh
way uh which can replace
uh another uh trade
ways uh including soya's
channel
and it's twice
almost twice less by kilometers
than uh soyez
channel it could be very profitable for
a russian economy for the global economy
as well it's one and secondly is uh is
the development of the technologies of
taking gas and oil
from the
sea
[Music]
in the articulation
technologically it's not so easy to do
because
the ice is
moving
but now
the new technologies probably will allow
uh to do it and
a lot of specialized geologists
regard that arctic ocean has a
tremendous
supply of gas and oil and if you may
know now they're developing uh global
economy need more and more energy uh
that wise those who
will be able to take uh uh gasoline oil
from the arctic ocean uh will has great
uh uh benefits okay so it's resource
which is what you're saying
okay uh wolfgang just i'd like to cross
over to you you want to say something or
comment on on that
yep i just would like to add that the
arctic is also of significance because
it's the petrol and lounge area for
russian ballistic missile submarines
right well one more reason yeah the
control over this um wolfgang i'd also
like to ask you um
we've been talking there about you know
having ports that are warm water or
ports that can be accessed
how has russia tried to secure allies or
partners in the region to get poor
access i mean syria has been a key ally
through
through the war in syria what about you
know egypt or cyprus or greece or libya
well one must not forget the position of
russia in the in africa is not that bad
as it is frequently perceived in the
west there are many african countries
with a warm and close relationship to
moscow
and especially from president to
president putin so this must be always
kept kept in mind and i would say there
are several options for the russians to
find a naval bases in africa especially
on the african east coast
so with regard to libya for the time
being although there are russian
mercenaries currently present in libya i
think it is highly unlikely highly
unlikely that there could be any libyan
ruler who would allow the russians to
establish a naval base in let's say
tobruk why because the relationship with
the west with europe is much more
important for libya than the
relationship with moscow sure
lawrence brennan we've got about a
minute left i can see you wanted to add
something there please take the floor
sure uh for more than 100 years uh
russian and friendly naval forces have
worked together in the far north at the
end of world war 1 1917 1918 uh british
and u.s naval forces were at romance and
archangel and uh
towards the end of the war in later
years uh us and other naval forces were
in vladivostok for many reasons through
through world war ii a lot of goods were
transported from the united states to
russia via vladivostok and in 1918 1919
uh the western allies were concerned
that japan would try to seize uh
vladivostok in the warm water courts in
northern russia
so this is a long-term problem uh with
some good historical precedent well
worth discussing at a conference
all right we'll have to leave it there
uh as you say we could have an entire
conference just on that uh for time
though thank you very much to all of our
guests sergey markov uh wolfgang pusdai
and lawrence brennan
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story from me
kim vanel and the whole team here in
doha bye-bye for now
[Music]